can i read you a plot
okay
let's let's end our conversations in a
poem i love it it's by
pierce by shelley probably
mispronouncing the name
but i think the right way to pronounce
it thank you thank you
um
i'm ozzy mandius i met a traveler from
an antique land who said
two vast and trunkless legs of stone
stand in the desert
near them on the sand
half sunk
as shattered visage lies whose frown and
wrinkled lip and sneer of cold command
tell that its sculptor well those
passions read which yet survive stamped
on these lifeless things the hand that
mocked them and the heart that fed and
on the pedestal these words appear
my name is ozymandias king of kings
look on my works ye mighty and despair
nothing beside remains around the decay
of that colossal wreck boundless and
bare the lone and level sand stretch far
away
all gone
behold the the king look on my works ye
mighty and despair
and despair uh even though we'll be
forgotten in the sands of time
duncan i'm just so glad that you exist
and you put so much love into the world
over the past many years that i've
gotten a chance to enjoy it by being
your fan
thank you so much for continuing that
and for sharing a bit of love with me
today can we be friends let's be friends
in real time in the real world in 3d
space nothing is real but yes in this
particular slice of the
multi-dimensional world we live in
it will be an honor and a pleasure thank
you for having me on your show love you
duncan i love you thank you lex
you